hello human
[Music]
what does internet live me basically
it's where all the people you love from
the internet come together in real life
do a show and the night show goes back
on the internet a couple days later they
couldn't be more clear
the meatballs are fighting over the
meatballs up here like people are people
too
[Music]
- - Holtz and bandana Oh Donald Trump
doesn't have a clue about New York City
you know what Tom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you like me
[Music]
[Music]
I bet you wanted to see me drive
you lied knowing this
the upper hand here
big please not another fan
so what you as a fit crank company I sit
down
[Music]
let's go
do you special whistle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning did you sleep okay oh sorry
I thought you were my boyfriend where's
my boyfriend
oh he's here tonight oh hi babe okay
shut up I told my boyfriend who I
definitely haven't is for sure in this
audience and I was coming here and he
was like what internet culture babe you
need to get online basically the
Internet is a place you can go but not
like with your body but in your brain
and it's not fun it feels like work even
though no one is paying you to be there
all right you guys they're tasty is the
home of food on the Internet
so for tonight's show we want to do
something special with tasty to really
wrap it all together and that is why
tonight we have a competition for you
people between cultural Titans from a
part of the country with a rich culinary
history put your hands together everyone
for the ladies of the Jersey Shore
[Music]
[Applause]
so real quick before we get into this if
you watch the show its portrayed that it
seems like the men of the Jersey Shore
are the ones doing the cooking during
Sunday dinner is that the case do you
guys cook real quick down the line what
would you say are your signature dishes
Nicole what's your signature dish
I mean grilled cheese out is looking
Deena chicken marsala chicken marsala
from Deena
Angelina what's your specialty I drink
vodka when I'm me I like to wear like a
good chicken parm chicken parm burnt
choice don't joy all right so guys let's
get into this competition ladies we've
got a challenge for you that should make
you feel right at home after yet another
family vacay we've laid out everything
that you need to make the most amazing
Jersey sub of your lives the challenges
he says build your own sandwich
anything goes after you finish your sub
trations will be judged by the hands of
tasty Alvin's Oh Alvin Commedia hello
all right ladies are you ready no all
right we're gonna set the timer on your
marks get set
sup go okay so today well reach oh
everybody's reaching for the sauces
right now
I see Angelina's trying to stack up that
meat ingredients stealing going on right
now this is a noble Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the meatballs are fighting over the
meatballs up here the vinegars in the
antis so here's what we're gonna do
Alvin you want to take a walk around and
cut yourself a piece of subs and we'll
hear what everyone's made I will do my
best
Jennifer we'll start with you I prepared
a classic Italian all the meats the
cheese's the oil the mayo salt and
pepper pepper damn Oh Angelina what did
you make I made the best freakin
sandwich in this whole entire thing
Cheetos [ __ ] disgusting right
Deena what did you prepare for us
tonight I did try it into a real Italian
you know I got the meats I do like
jalapenos I like spicy cuz I'm a spicy
meatball hey Nicole what did you prepare
for elleven
honestly I'm just here many alcohols
Cake Boss salami onions and a nice um
Italian dressing so nice you're gonna
pick hers I mean I should be good
all right Alvin you've tried this you've
tried their wares quickly come down
there and let's have a quick convoy it's
gonna be a hard choice but we'll see
what we can do it's gotta be tough
people all right ladies and gentlemen we
have a winner
it was a very tough call very tough but
everyone the winner of tonight's contest
is Deena
[Applause]
that's right thought I cook every night
pictures I know what the man would like
everyone Congrats Edina and the fist
bump in our coconut village in my
[Applause]
Florida man charged with a song with a
deadly weapon after throwing it out of
the Gator through a Wendy's
drive-through window
[Music]
[Applause]
all about getting the juice I got
getting people juice and of course my
favorite JoJo's juice sensation where I
for juice on my head
by choice yes that is a real thing that
I do in every video I pour juice over my
head and today for the special occasion
I thought I would bring JoJo's juice
back about to happen
I have three liquids I got spaghetti
sauce melt and blue pains and I need
your guys's help to help me decide what
to pour over my head how about fried
spaghetti sauce
for milk
the odds for blue pegs
[Applause]
all right well blue paint was definitely
in the winter but I'm gonna do the most
Jojo thing possible and I'm pouring all
of them over my head
Wow
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
you have to be careful online though
because people on there make stuff up
like they're making it up to scare you
like climate change
okay I'll believe it when it gets hotter
outside which actually yeah it is
getting hotter outside but I think
that's just because the clouds like move
to another spot temporarily hi I'm Ben
Smith I'm the editor in chief of
BuzzFeed news joined here by Charlaine
and Bill DeBlasio one of the things we
cover is the 2020 campaign the trail
these these folks are new york's
candidates so this is kind of in an
apocalyptic week in new york floods you
know blackouts plagues are we gonna have
plague maybe not heatwave no plague no
plague heat wave heat wave is climate
change gonna make this city
uninhabitable no but climate change is
incredibly real and dangerous and we've
got to do a lot to change what we do and
this whole national election is a chance
to decide that we will do the green New
Deal who believes in green New Deal what
we need for this country but no we're
still this is a place that can work if
we take the right steps now as you hear
your husband is running for president
Michelle Obama at one point described
the office of first lady as a very nice
prison and I wonder like do you dread
that well I kind of look at a little
differently I think the whole thing is
quite an adventure and it's what you
make it I've always been very active and
make sure that every day is a little bit
of an adventure she is an activist she
would be if elected she would be the
most activist first lady in the history
of this country guaranteed
the current president of United States
singled you out on Twitter today he's
very concerned about people throwing
water on new york city police officers
and he said that it was unacceptable and
that you have been failing to stand up
for cops you should stand up for cops
what do you say to the president I think
Donald Trump doesn't have a clue about
New York City
he has no idea about life in the city
this is a guy who said we should bring
stop and frisk back to New York City
which would have been the worst possible
thing so I have something to say to
Donald Trump tonight which is I
challenge you Donald Trump to come to
New York City and I will debate you
about what's right for New York City and
BuzzFeed can host it because he doesn't
understand New York City and when his
presidency is over really soon he will
not be welcome back in New York City
ladies and gentlemen Bill DeBlasio
chirlane McCray thank you so much for
joining
Vado on Alec Burke hi I'm Zach safranin
we are the hosts of BuzzFeed news am 2dm
alright well here to before I'm waving
through a window an Internet spire song
from the show dear Evan Hanson we'd like
to present Sam Primack
I've learned to slam on the brake before
I even turn the key before I make the
mistake before I lead with the worst of
me
give them no reason to stare no slipping
up if you slip away so I got nothing to
share no I got nothing to say step out
step out of the Sun if you keep get
burned step out step out of the Sun
because you've learned
as uvula
on the outside always looking in will I
ever be more than I've always been cuz
I'm tap tap tapping on the glass I'm
waving through window I try to speak but
nobody can hear so I wait around for an
answer to appear on watch watch watching
people pass I'm waving through window
can anybody see it's anybody waving
back at me
[Applause]
we start with stars in our eyes we start
believing that we belong but every Sun
doesn't rise and no one tells you where
you went wrong step out step out of the
Sun if you keep get burned
step out step out of the Sun because
you've learned because you've learned on
the outside always looking in will I
ever be more than I've always been cuz
I'm tapped out tapping on the glass
to window I try to speak but nobody can
hear so I wait around for an answer to
be
watch watch watching me for pies waiting
Oh can anybody see
is anybody waving when you're falling in
a forest and there's nobody around do
you ever really crash sound when you're
phone in a forest and there's nobody
around do you ever really crash when
you're falling in a forest and there's
nobody around whoever really crash or
even make a sound when you're falling in
a forest and there's nobody around do
you ever really crash or even make a
sound did I even make a sound did I even
make
make a sound it's like I never made a
sound will I ever make a sound always
more than I've always been cause um tap
tap tapping on the
where
[Music]
I try to speak but nobody can hear so I
wait around
watch watch watching people time
[Music]
Oh can anybody see this anybody baby
[Music]
whoa
three two one hit it please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
five
crowd we've got techies yes we've got
influencers yes I can tell I know I'm a
mom but I can tell you're an influencer
you're influencing me right now yes you
are now my name is Dean ebed Remini okay
and I don't work in the meme industry or
mean biz okay but they are very near and
dear to my heart how many y'all want to
see a meme
[Applause]
stop it
okay stop grumpy cat that cat is pissed
y'all seriously is there anything
funnier than grumpy cat I don't know
let's find out okay slide guy let's find
out
[Applause]
god damn god damn that is funny [ __ ] god
damn that is funny I am loving it oh my
god you guys okay as much as I love that
I have got a mean that's gonna blow that
out the water next one to remember this
one yes yes you'll remember yet yep the
hole they're all cracking
they love it they love it yes okay you
guys
please listen up because here's some fun
facts this is the reason I'm here
tonight okay since this meme was dropped
in 2017 okay buzz feed all of you have
shared it over 6 point 1 billion times
another fact the distracted dude that
guy his name is Trevor beard Remini that
dude is my son
that is my son shame on you shame on you
BuzzFeed the lives that you have ruined
yes what Trevor my son does for a living
guess what he does you no no do you know
what methods do you know what methods
okay that's what he does just left
meth he's a full junkie now Marissa the
one who's holding his hand once the meme
drop she left him
alright we had gone wedding-dress
shopping a week prior all right and you
know what she does now for context she
was a stripper before the top on tops
off now okay that's on you must feed
that is on you okay
meme people are people to meme people
are people to the girl the one who's
checking out okay last week I [ __ ] you
not she shot a lion she shot a lion
Point Blank okay she's a big-game hunter
now okay she kills rafts all that
because of BuzzFeed alright stop sharing
this meme stop it that is my son
before I go I want to show you all one
more mean sigh god
[Applause]
good night Lord a man slaps Florida
woman with a cheeseburger upside the
head he attacks
while she was sleeping right there - got
that burger all over what's going on
everybody you feel good I'm Jason who
knows me as the guy who attaches himself
to young internet stars for fame and
fortune I'm here tonight to elevate
three legendary memes and their creators
to the highest honor on the Internet
it's the inaugural class of BuzzFeed's
Internet Hall of Fame
our first honorees created a
breakthrough video in 2016 which took
them from zero to Ellen in a matter of
days damn Daniel damn Daniel damn Daniel
back at it again with the white vans
dusty men with those white vans we'd
like to induct him to BuzzFeed's
Internet Hall of Fame Josh Holtz and
damn Daniel here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
Congrats have you considered working
with other Daniels in the future just
this one I actually have many of times
multiple of times actually Daniel and
you wore white vans today didn't you I
did wear white vans why don't you do it
here we go guys this is what it would be
like go ahead do it
dan Daniel not gonna begin with the
white I mean is that incredible our next
honoree has been a meme since all the
way back in the Internet stone age of
2008 she showed us the devastating power
of a little smirk we'd like to induct
into Busby's Internet Hall of Fame
disaster girl
[Applause]
he's have to go himself zowie wrong how
are you Joey pretty good how did you
come up with disaster girl the internet
came up with it for me oh isn't that
funny and what are you up to these days
I'm in college and I'm working in
Shanghai right now okay in Shanghai what
Shanghai okay got it thanks for making
all of us feel stupid
awesome okay Zoe thank you so much this
is such an honor to be here with you
give it up for Zoe Roth everybody our
final honoree has been internet famous
since she was 18 months old she famously
smelled like beef but assured us were
all like two inducted you must be Jenna
at Hall of Fame hey Ryan
[Applause]
how are you I'm great thank you are you
having fun being in New York yes I'm
having a lot of fun yes I am and have
you thought of any cool characters while
you're here so I guess so
what is your favorite line out of all
your characters I smell like beef of
course and where'd you come up with that
one so I ate beef that night and I
looked at the sky and it was purple and
I was just like I smell like beef all
right so last thing can you tell me that
I'm winning it life I really need it
you're winning at life you're winning
you're winning at life that's amazing
either you're amazing congratulations on
being inducted into the internet Hall of
Fame you'll be writing you a check for
four billion dollars write it as you get
off stage okay wonderful on behalf of
all of the internet please accept these
priceless trophies no joke here we go
Jojo this is a new suit don't even don't
even
[Applause]
Toto's - Jojo - congratulations are all
part of BuzzFeed's first error internet
Hall of Fame may your phone always be in
landscape your Wi-Fi crispy and your
comments be blessedly troll free
[Applause]
who knows this song somebody say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
on the tractor thing all in my blood
CD Don my ass my life is a movie
[Music]
can't nobody tell me
[Music]
can't nobody tell me nothing
what you sign each chapter
[Music]
Thank You New York
[Applause]
how sweet the sound that saved
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but
ah
to us great
[Music]
to fee
[Music]
let me whole
really
[Music]
ah
[Music]
love but now the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]